هذا هو الطريق الأكثر أمانًا للخروج من باهاموت
ولكنه ليس آمنًا على الإطلاق، مقطع الفيديو الذي
حصلت عليه CNN للمنظر من
مركبة مدرعة أوكرانية يُظهر
الأرض القاحلة التي أصبحت عليها المدينة، وقد
هربت مارينا وييفينيا في مركبة كهذه من
بنايتهم في باهاموت  كان مختبئًا في القصف يوم
الخميس الماضي مما أسفر عن مقتل ثلاثة بينهم
حفيد يافانيا البالغ من العمر 33 عامًا
وكان علي مساعدته، كما تتذكر، لكنني
لم أستطع فعل أي شيء
[موسيقى] لقد
انتظروا في منازلهم المدمرة مع
الموتى لمدة ثلاثة أيام قبل أن
يتمكن الجيش من إنقاذهم.
كانت ابنة مارينا متزوجة من
حفيد يفينيا
ماذا سأقول لابنتي كريست
مارينا هي وأحفادي في
بولندا،
هذا الملجأ القريب من تشاسيفيار يوفر
لهم بعض الراحة والدفء لكنهم
ما زالوا ليسوا في مأمن من الخطر،
هذه المدينة تقع ضمن نطاق
البنادق الروسية  ومنذ أن
بدأت معركة البكموت قبل سبعة أشهر،
تعرضت للقصف بشكل منتظم
في هذا اليوم، كان الروس يطلقون
ذخائر حارقة على المدينة
مصممة لإشعال الحرائق،
وأظهر لنا أحد السكان كبسولة مستهلكة من
الصاروخ، ويقول المسؤولون إنه ربما يكون هناك
1000 مدني.  من
الممكن إجلاء الهيكل المتبقي ولكن لا يبدو أن
هناك الكثير من محتجزي
ألكساندر يسحب الحطب إلى المنزل، لا توجد
كهرباء أو مياه جارية هنا، لقد
هرب إلى تشاسيفياتا من سيفيرسك على بعد ساعة
من هنا حيث دمر منزله،
هل سيغادر نعم لا، يجيبني
ماتت زوجتي هنا ودفن والداي هنا
يرأس الإدارة العسكرية للبلدة
منذ أبريل الماضي ونحن نحاول
إقناع الناس بالمغادرة والتحدث معهم
والتفكير معهم، أخبرني ولكننا
لا نستطيع أن نجعلهم يغادرون
مرة أخرى، رفض كبار السن والعجزة  لمغادرة
بن ويتمان رغم خطر سي إن
شرق أوكرانيا